voilà nous voici revenus dans notre
époque tous nos amis sont là elle est
formidable machine à remonter le temps
mais oui seulement casimir nous n'avons
pas retrouvé mon casque
heureusement monsieur travelling n'est
pas encore arrivé
attendez attendez attendez
tous nos amis ne sont pas encore au
courant de ce qui nous est arrivé hier
je vais donc leur expliquer mais je vous
dirai ensuite ce que nous allons faire
d'accord d'accord bon ben pendant ce
temps là julie va m'offrir une petite
limonade à casimir je n'ai plus de
casque comment veux tu que je fasse vrai
bon alors je vais vous expliquer ce qui
nous est arrivé
y est
la machine à voyager dans le temps de
casimir a emporté le kiosque de julie à
travers l'espace à l'époque des gaulois
ne nous souvenons plus exactement de la
dame alors depuis hier soir une
recherchons à travers les mois et les
années ça vous paraît incroyable savez
la machine à voyager dans le temps de
casimir est vraiment extraordinaire et
le plus grave c'est que monsieur
travelling veut construire à la place du
kiosque de julie un kiosque à sa façon
nous devons donc retrouver le casque de
julie avant que monsieur travelling ne
commence la construction du cirque mais
comment allons-nous faire un monsieur
très vite arriver bientôt pour écoutez
je sais assez bien piloter la machine de
casimir julie et moi nous repartons dans
l'espace oui moi un mois alors qu'est ce
que je vais faire avec les émirs toi mon
vieux j'étais réserver la mission la
plus importante
pendant gens absolument pas casinière
alors explique moi de quoi il s'agit et
voilà casimir tu vas rester ici il faut
absolument empêcher monsieur travelling
de commencer la construction de son
propre kiosque avant que nous y ramener
celui de julie du passé d'accord mais
pourquoi ne pas tout dire à monsieur
travelling mais c'est partout et donc du
tout mais monsieur travelling a
tellement envie de construire son propre
kiosque il commença aussi tous les
travaux et vous savez peut-être que si
quelque chose est mis à l'emplacement de
ton casque je lis ne pourront plus
jamais le ramener du passé je pourrais
l'attacher à un arbre tu es fou casimiri
il n'est pas question de repayer la
violence est interdit dans l'île aux
enfants en pis j'essayerai de trouver
une autre méthode alors débrouille toi
[Musique]
évidemment je je ne peux pas l'attacher
à un arbre
je pourrais donc plus proposer d'autres
de monter un groupe de gars avec moi
mais il n'acceptera jamais
j'ai une autre idée
arrêtée immédiatement
vous voyez bien que je suis en train de
commencer mon cher vous faites ce que
vous voulez mais à mon avis vous avez
tort que voulez-vous dire devriez
d'abord lire la lettre que je vous
apporte est pour moi une lettre
importante trop belle de toute façon je
reçois toujours de l'être très
importante oui mais celle ci est très
important et de qui est elle un deviner
attendez attendez du directeur de
l'opéra de rio de janeiro non attendez
attendez du grand chanteur alberto
cassoulet pas le moins du monde
à aa et les deux mois de vous à moi je
n'osais pas vous le dire de vive voix
alors je voulais écrire
et on voit monsieur tao là là c'est mal
écrit monsieur travelling je veux bien
signer un contrat pour que vous me
promener à travers le monde dans une
cage comme un horrible et gros monstre à
une condition jouer un sketch avec vous
signés casira cher grands artistes dans
mes bras d'accord je signe immédiate ne
connaissez même pas les conditions du
combat mais lorsqu'elle je signe tout de
suite vous en paierez pas d'accord mais
il faut malgré tout que je vous lis mon
sketch au moins d'après votre manuscrit
c'est une pièce en cinq zones ont non
seulement un petit sketch de trois ou
quatre heures à les et je ne m'en vais
vous m'écoutez alors j'y anime
par un beau matin de printemps
tout était calme dans l'île aux enfants
les oiseaux chantaient
lorsque soudain sur un sentier du petit
bois alors vous me dites
méfie toi gros monstres nous je vais te
priver de dessert
ça suffit casimir ça suffit non ce n'est
pas écrit dans le texte je me fiche de
votre texte je me fiche de votre texte
que je veux c'est construire ou kiosques
et personne non personne ne pourra
m'empêcher
nous
mais comment est il arrivé là mais
monsieur travelling le kiosque n'a
jamais bougé oui oui bon je crois que je
ne me sens pas bien du tout c'est
toujours bon chemin sûr j'en suis sûr je
me sens très mal là où
la pauvre monsieur travail vim bravo
casimir
[Musique]